This is the head of the World Health
Organization Dr Tedros Adhanom Ghebreyesus.
Earlier this year he DM'd me on
Twitter. He said I should come to the DRC
and see for myself how complicated Ebola
was to control there.
A few months later I was flying to the Eastern DRC.
One of the first things I noticed once I landed
was the presence of tanks and soldiers.
There's been decades of conflict in the
area and war and political instability
are really at the root of why Ebola
has been so hard to contain.
This is a photo outside of an Ebola centre. There's
soldiers stationed behind sandbags at
the entrance. The reason they're there is
that this particular Ebola center had
already been attacked twice, had been
burnt to the ground. But at the same time
the presence of soldiers might be
intimidating for some people. And that's
on top of the fact that Ebola is a
terrifying disease and then the response
to Ebola is also strange and terrifying.
Someone in this household was diagnosed
with Ebola and now there's these Ebola
responders dressed in these weird white
Tyvek suits who come in and just douse
all of somebody's belongings in chlorine.
Some people have even set up chairs to
watch the whole scene.
But the care being offered to
people is improving compared
to previous outbreaks.
Here's within an Ebola treatment
centre and there's a plastic cube around
a patient that allows family members to
see in and patients to see out. In
addition this time there's not only
intravenous fluids that are given to
every patient but people are getting
experimental Ebola drugs and two of
those Ebola drugs have now been proven
to be up to 90% effective if people get
them early. And the other bright spot is
that there's now an Ebola vaccine that's
been widely deployed in this outbreak
for the first time. So you would think
that this outbreak would be contained by
now but it's not and there's a few
reasons for that. One of them is that
it's difficult to know who is at high
risk. Also vaccine teams can't vaccinate
people who don't want to be vaccinated. And people aren't getting experimental
drugs if they don't go into Ebola
centres. What they'll do first is go to
the places they're used to going so that
could be a pastor, it could be a
traditional healer, it could be a small
pharmacy or a small clinic. These sort of
pharmacies are just all over the place.
There's hundreds of them. You can see
like a snake around a chalice that's
sort of an insignia.
This is a photo inside of one of these health facilities.
This woman is feverish and rather than
have her mix with all of the other
patients that might show up there
they've decided to put patients who have
symptoms of Ebola in one area so that
they're separated from others. So in this
room a mother's sitting by her child and
the doctor thinks the child should
perhaps go to an Ebola treatment
centre but the mother doesn't want her
child to go. And if you can put yourself
in the mother's shoes,
the Ebola centre's about an hour away,
she'd have to be separated, she can't
hold her child, she can't be there next
to him. This is the kind of mistrust or
reluctance that comes from a place of
love and concern and not conflict
This is a photo of an Ebola checkpoint. These
are set up to contain the outbreak. What
happens is when people go past they have
their temperature taken and if they have
a fever they're not allowed to travel
through a checkpoint. And these
checkpoints have been very helpful but
at the same time they're not bulletproof.
People with Ebola have now traveled to
Goma in North Kivu which is a very
international city and they've now
traveled 700 kilometers south.
What all of this comes down to is that Dr Tedros
has a huge amount of work in front
of him. The world has completely ignored
a humanitarian crisis in the DRC for a
quarter century. That crisis is why the
Ebola outbreak has now killed more than
2,000 people and if we keep ignoring
Ebola too - it's only going to help the virus
spread.